on this Tuesday night getting ready to
be grounded WestJet Pilots set a date
for strike action it is a very emotional
day for all of us what's behind it and
what it could be for your summer
vacation
Alberta's Relentless wildfires the
multiplying number of displaced people
and their choke hold on air quality
real fears about artificial intelligence
I think
and behind chat GPT urges regulation as
the use of AI expands
plus they were busted for the biggest
jewel heist in modern history why
critics say their prison time doesn't
fit the infamous crime
[Music]
foreign
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin tonight with news about a
possible pilot strike right before the
May long weekend the union representing
Pilots at WestJet and swoop have issued
a 72-hour strike notice it means nearly
1900 Pilots could walk off the job at 3
A.M mountain time on Friday grounding
the airline's entire fleet of around 180
Aircraft and affecting 700 flights per
day and the thousands of passengers
booked on them contract talks are still
underway but the airline says it could
lock out the pilots before the strike
deadline and gaviola has our top story
tonight
air Travelers should brace for Grounded
flights cancellations and disruptions
starting Friday we
attendance
as Personnel that will also be affected
by this and we also have our passengers
that have have booked tickets and expect
to get to the destinations that they've
booked it is a very emotional day for
all of us here among the sticking points
between the two sides compensation
WestJet says their salaries are among
the highest in Canada pilots who are in
demand globally say they're severely
underpaid by North American Standards
without the pilot you know the industry
is on its knees westjet's response to
the strike notice a lockout notice
saying it sincerely regrets the
inconvenience and uncertainty this
causes guests adding it is committed to
reaching a deal travel agents are
scrambling to find Alternatives
including less than direct routes
sometimes by a Toronto or Montreal or in
some cases the United States just to
reassure people that they will actually
get to their destination for for that
cruise or wedding or family event that
can't be postponed by two or three days
while they're delayed on travel the cost
to Consumers time money and effort
it's probably a good idea for them to
book unfortunately another flight on
another airline possibly with a
possibility of getting a full refund of
that should WestJet come through if
disruptions continue for weeks air
travel could rapidly become a headache
during Peak summer season if there are
fewer flights because of you know
ongoing strikes or prime like this
flights are going to be even more
expensive for The Travelers just the
threat of action will have an impact on
forward bookings or WestJet this will
damage when people book with the airline
because they'll be concerned about what
happens in the future even if this issue
is resolved many say the reputational
damage has already begun and gaviola
Global News Toronto
Canada's transport minister is in
Detroit to announce a new cross-border
electric vehicle Corridor Omar al-gabra
teamed up with his American counterpart
the plan is for EV charging stations
from Kalamazoo Michigan to Quebec City
one of the busiest passenger and trade
routes between the US and Canada the
Chargers will be no more than 80
kilometers apart along the nearly 1400
kilometer route South Korea has a huge
electric battery market and prime
minister Justin Trudeau is there now
ahead of the G7 Summit in Japan on his
first official visit to the country both
sides are pledging to build stronger
ties and move away from dependence on
China Mackenzie gray is traveling with
the Prime Minister Mackenzie
Donna for the second time this calendar
year Justin Trudeau has come to Asia
selling Canada's new plan to contain
chime in the bustling center of a Seoul
massive Billboards light the night sky
and the Koreans hope they'll soon be
made from Key Canadian materials
interesting diversifying surprise of the
critical minerals and Canada can be a
very good choice eager to reduce their
Reliance on critical minerals from China
the Koreans have turned to Canada to
help fuel the second largest
semiconductor and electric battery
Market in the world and Justin Trudeau
is ready to help
prime minister and the South Korean
president who recently met in Ottawa was
signed a deal to expand critical mineral
trade on this trip an example of what
the Prime Minister hopes will become a
Hallmark of the liberal's indo-pacific
strategy the plan for stronger business
and political ties of friendly Asian
countries to limit China's influence in
the region one thing about Canada the
world's looking to us for energy in
particular LNG and for critical minerals
and you're seeing the Investments come
now we need to make sure we have the
trade enabling infrastructure to get
those products to Market it seems that
every time I'm in Asia there's something
going on back home but concern over
another deal between the feds in a major
South Korean company could put a damper
on the tour multinational car makers to
Lantus and the Korean partner battery
maker LG Energy Solutions so this week
the Liberals haven't followed through on
their promise to support an EV plant in
Windsor and they've put a stop to
construction industry Minister Francois
Philippe champagne blames The Province
if we're on the end that that drama
we've been saying over the last few days
it's only for our friends in Ontario to
pay their fair share Canada and South
Korea will also sign a new pact to
increase the number of young people
allowed to work and study in both
countries which will increase the
already 220 000 people in Canada who say
they have Korean Origins I don't think
there was a time Korea and Canada was
close this now once the Prime Minister
wraps up his two-day trip to South Korea
the fly to Hiroshima to join other world
leaders for the G7 in Japan Donna all
right Mackenzie gray and Seoul South
Korea thanks a hearing is underway in
Ottawa to probe allegations of a
campaign of intimidation by the
communist government in China
conservative MP Michael song says
Canadian intelligence officials
confirmed to him he and his family were
targeted by a Chinese Consular official
who has since been expelled from the
country and Chong told the hearing he
believes the public finding out about
Chinese interference through leaks to
the media is a symptom of a national
security system that isn't working our
chief political correspondent David
Aiken is following this David
well Donna Michael Chong appeared before
the procedure and house Affairs
committee earlier this evening and this
is the committee that has spent the last
few weeks looking at the broader issue
of foreign interference in Canada's
elections but now it is focusing in on
the Chong case and all parties want to
know more about what happened the last
several weeks have been a trying time
for me and my family
but it is important to note that my case
is but only one of many Canadians who
have been threatened on Canadian soil by
authoritarian governments and who have
suffered in silence in a way I wish this
hadn't happened to you but perhaps it
will prompt us to to do even better in
the in the years to come a key question
for the committee as it begins its probe
into Chong's case is why wasn't Chong
told about this alleged plot back in
2021 back when he was meeting with
policy experts at the University of
Toronto near the very Chinese Consulate
where the alleged plot was hatched to
know that just a mere several blocks
away for several years somebody was
actively trying to collect information
about me and my family in the PRC was
deeply disconcerting and to know that
the government of Canada knew about this
and didn't do anything about it was
deeply disappointing as for the
conservatives they say the buck stops
with the Prime Minister and that he is
ultimately responsible for the failure
to inform Chong about about the alleged
plot it's clear that the sole
responsibility for the Machinery of
government is the prime minister's the
PM says he only found out about this
alleged Chong plot earlier this month
and within days his government expelled
the Chinese Diplomat alleged to have
been in on the plot and the PM ordered
Canada's security agencies to
immediately notify ministers bump it
right up to the political level whenever
Canada's security agencies pick up
mention of any threat no matter how
trivial against any member of Canada's
parliament Donna David Aiken in Ottawa
thanks
in Alberta the Heat and high winds are
unrelenting more than 80 wildfires are
now burning across that Province
Canadian Armed Forces Personnel have
been deployed to some of the communities
under threat including Fox Creek and
Grand Prairie our need to garcha is in
Valley View nitu that town is also on
the front lines and was evacuated
yesterday
that's right Donna and you can see one
of the police blockades behind me you
might also be able to see some of the
Thick Smoke these are just some of the
clear signs that the wildfire that
forced this entire Community to flee
came very close
downed power line still smoldering
Tuesday beside Highway 43 about a
hundred kilometers east of Grand Prairie
and there's an active fire fight above
Flames came within 10 kilometers of
Valley View people in the small town of
about 2 000 were forced to leave on
Monday
fogazer visibility
yeah like everything is white as if like
the town like it has been eaten by the
smoke residents like Eric talvis and his
family fled to an evacuation Center in
nearby White Court already supporting
hundreds of evacuees from other
communities I'm really petrified about
the situation that has had happened
because this is my first time to be able
to experience these with new evacuations
adding to the more than 20 thousand
people already displaced across Alberta
he says tensions are high but Community
Support is going to get them through it
a sentiment shared by Valley View
resident melodyne de Merchant it blows
me away
how it all came together Community just
I mean businesses people strangers you
know just everybody came forward she's
checking up on her now evacuated
agricultural complex
for over a week it sheltered animals for
evacuees until they were evacuated
themselves we turned it into the sort of
command center for the pet evacuation at
one point we had 167 dogs and cats and
two turtles there's no doubt that this
Wildfire got close to Valley View and we
understand that for people in the
community it must have been a very
frightening event fire officials say
Canadian Armed Forces members have been
deployed to areas like this one where
communities and lives are most at risk
provincial officials say shifting winds
and strong gusts have created dangerous
conditions on the ground and they can
use all the help they can get including
from the Canadian Armed Forces and from
The public's diligence as they say
historically this time of year most
fires have been human-caused Donna all
right Nitro garcha in Valley View
Alberta thank you a shift in the wind
has pushed the forest fire smoke South
Heather urich's West is in Calgary
Heather
Donna Wildfire smoke has become all too
familiar during the summer months
especially in western Canada but Tuesday
saw one of the worst air quality days
for Calgary in recent memory at the top
of the scale at 10 plus or very high
risk now officials are warning everyone
to take the health warnings seriously
with children older adults and anyone
with respiratory lung conditions in
particular being urged to avoid any
heavy activity outside now the situation
is set to improve slightly heading into
Wednesday but forecasters say the Smoky
Skies will be with us through the
weekend Donna all right as will the Heat
and the wind Heather York's Weston
Calgary thanks the federal government is
proposing changes to Canada's bail
system intended to make it harder for
repeat offenders to be given bail it's a
response to cases of people accused of
committing violent crimes while out on
bail teria Israel looks at what the
government wants to change and how it's
being received
police officers have died on the job
since September including Ontario
Provincial Police Constable Greg
pershalla the man accused of murdering
him was out on bail at the time a person
should not be out on bail if they have a
History of Violence just Minister David
lametti has tabled reforms to reverse
the onus from prosecutors to the accused
that means the person behind bars now
needs to prove why they should be
released what we're doing for certain
violent offenses is changing the default
position and and making sure that it is
only in cases where there isn't a threat
to public security that they will get
bail those offenses include weapons
charges the move comes after a public
push from police and the provinces I've
been a cop now for almost 37 years I've
never seen
circumstances like this last March every
single Premier and territorial leader
sent a letter to prime minister Justin
Trudeau pleading for bail reform the
federal government changed the laws back
in 2019 which the opposition says made
things worse Justin Trudeau is Catch and
Release
bail system has Unleashed a wave of
violent crime across the country you're
going to put some number on it but
criminal defense lawyers warned stricter
bail conditions can sometimes have
unintended consequences yeah the problem
with bail reform is that if you get it
wrong it can actually make the public
less safe if you detain someone they
actually are more likely to commit an
offense when they get out of jail
there are also fears that changes May
marginalize vulnerable populations like
black and Indigenous people our bail
system already presently detains
racialized people at a far higher rate
the Justice Minister calls these reforms
targeted and says there will be a review
period in the next five years but David
lametti could not say how many repeat
offenders this will affect
Global News Ottawa Canada's inflation
rate Rose slightly in April inflation
went up from 4.3 percent in March to 4.4
percent before this it was falling every
month since hitting an 8.1 percent peak
in June of 2022.
trying to control artificial
intelligence technology coming up what
The Man Behind chat GPT says needs to
happen
foreign
the head of the company responsible for
creating the artificial intelligence
chat bot chat GPT testified before U.S
Congress today he supports regulatory
guard rails to minimize harm from the
technology
my worst fears are that we cause
significant we the field the technology
the industry caused significant harm to
the world I think if this technology
goes wrong it can go quite wrong and we
want to be vocal about that we want to
work with the government to prevent that
from happening
Sam Altman is the CEO of open AI he says
his company's technology May destroy
some jobs but will also create new ones
he proposes creating an agency to issue
licenses for AI plus safety regulations
and tests it must pass before being
released to the public Tech Giants have
poured billions into the technology
calling it transformative but it's also
been cited in empowering scams and
spreading falsehoods which Altman agrees
is concerning
Advanced assault ahead Russia uses one
of its most expensive weapons to attack
Ukraine
the British government has announced it
will work with the Dutch government to
build an International Coalition to help
procure F-16 fighter jets for Ukraine
Britain has also promised to supply
hundreds of attack drones Ukraine is
relying on Western support to push back
Russian attacks overnight a barrage of
Russian missiles and drones hit Kiev as
Crystal gomancing Reports there's
evidence Russia deployed one of its most
advanced weapons a Hypersonic missile
that moves 10 times faster than the
speed of sound
images widely circulating on social
media show a nighttime barrage on Kiev
Ukraine claims it shot down six
Hypersonic missiles plus 12 other types
of bombs including explosive drones it's
clear that they want
to hit the very heart of the country and
to keep the call of Ukrainian Nation
dense the Russian defense Ministry
spokesperson says a Hypersonic ballistic
missile took out an American Patriot air
defense system one of the most expensive
donated weapons in Ukraine's Arsenal it
also claims to have destroyed seven
newly donated UK Storm Shadow missiles
Ukraine reported damages from falling
debris but would not say if any weapons
were lost
ukrainians did lose the little peace
they had when the air alert alarm
sounded early Tuesday morning countless
images have been shared of the haunting
thuds of explosions
and people scurrying away from Windows
some fled to shelters others were put in
the safest closest option all lives we
are protected
all missiles were shut down
including ballistic ones Vladimir
zielinski addressed a rare meeting of
the Council of Europe the 46 leaders May
approve a registry to help Ukraine track
damages a means of attempting to hold
Russia responsible for victim
compensation
Crystal commencing Global News London
the American Central Intelligence Agency
is appealing to Russians to share War
secrets with U.S spies
the every state
this video in Russian has been posted on
social media the CIA promises to protect
the safety of Russians if they make
contact through a portal on the dark web
the video which reflects on heroism and
endurance shows fictional characters
upset with their country grappling with
how to get in touch the CIA says it
wants to hear from Russian Military
Officers intelligence Specialists and
diplomats and says people around you may
not want to hear the truth but we do
Russia claims it hasn't paid attention
to the video and says its special
services track all Western spy activity
controversial sentence next to German
gangs punishment for a giant Jewel Heist
[Music]
the thieves who hit a museum in Germany
in 2019 hoped they get away with one of
the biggest jewel heists in history they
did for a while they stole more than 160
million dollars worth of jewelry but
today five of them face the music Mike
Armstrong reports
prosecutor had a delicate Balancing Act
to play in this case and may have missed
the mark the severity of the sentences
some have said don't match the
seriousness of the crime they blame a
controversial plea deal struck with the
thieves does a child and the presiding
judge says without an agreement the
stolen jewelry wouldn't have been
recovered
4 5 a.m November 25th 2019 power to the
neighborhood was knocked out by a
homemade explosive and thieves broke in
through a window they'd already cut a
hole in the iron grill over the window
days earlier now what they hit was one
of the oldest museums in Europe it's
called the green Vault housed in an
historic castle in the city of Dresden
the thieves knew what they were after in
a matter of minutes they stole 21 pieces
some dating as far back as the 17th
century as part of the plea deal the
thieves helped recover most of the
jewelry three pieces are still missing
and others were also damaged
the judge says the state can Now launch
civil lawsuits against the thieves the
men are all in their 20s and all members
of the same family the German tabloids
have called them the Remo clan members
are usually mixed up in extortion fraud
and robbery in return for the
confessions the men's sentences were
capped the stiffest sentence for the
five was six years and two months
sixth family member was acquitted the
judge says he had a watertight alibi
well the other reason the plea deal is
coming under Fire is it only included
the confession the men didn't have to
give information or incriminate anyone
else and experts say it's very likely
other members of the clan were involved
Mike Armstrong Global News
and that is global national for this
Tuesday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's your
Canada is Grant's Old Mill on sturgeon
Creek in Winnipeg it used to grind weed
into flower back in the 1800s thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow bye-bye
thank you
[Music]